reaction tonight from black leaders in
our community following raiders coach
john gruden's racially insensitive
comments and an email surfacing from a
decade ago victoria saha has our story
it's hurtful it's painful an email
surfacing 10 years later from coach john
gruden writing to an executive with the
washington football team complaining
about demarcus smith gruden said in this
email quote damborea smith has lips the
size of michelin tires and quote this
racially insensitive email is not
sitting well for wendell williams the
founder of dr martin luther king
committee of las vegas fighting for
racial equality is his mission i would
hope that people who
who easily make comments such as this
realize that is very hurtful gruden told
the wall street journal quote i was
upset i used a horrible way of
explaining it i don't think he's dumb i
don't think he's a liar i don't have a
racial bone in my body and i've proven
that for 58 years williams says he hopes
gruden takes this time to reflect on the
power his hurtful words have but his
poor choice of words from a decade ago
should not be held against him he is a
person that
our community has embraced
here in las vegas
the issue is important
we hate to hear anytime somebody makes
comments like that but i think that he
deserves an opportunity to grow and
learn from this
victoria zaha 8 news now